انا هايدي عاصم
خريجه صيدله جامعه القاهره
متجوزه وعندي ولدين وبنت وبنت من ضمن اربع
بنات لمامتي بابايا
هبدا كده التاج بتاعتي بثمن كلمات وعايزه
كل واحد وواحده قاعد يشوفوا الكلمات دي
فكروا الكلمات دي
يفكروا الكلمات دي ايه اول حاجه بتيجي في
دماغك مع كل كلمه والكلمات دي مرتبطه ببعض
ولا لا ولو مرتبطه ممكن تبقى مرتبطه ازاي
اول حاجه جولز اهداف
تشالنجرز تحديات
هارد بويك شغل جامد
فوكس تركيز
تحفيز
شغف
مسؤوليات
الحلم الكبير
خلينا نرجع لسلايد دي
هي دي السلايد اللي انا هتكلم فيها وكل
فتره من فترات حياه كل واحد فينا في
الكلمات دي ممكن تبقى هي اللي بتتكلم عن
الفتره اللي هي بتتكلم فيها يعني
اول تشالنج كان موجود في حياتي ويمكن احنا
النهارده في الجامعه وممكن عندنا الصغيره
هو زهور جوزي اللي هو ابو ولادي دلوقتي في
حياتي في سن بدري جدا وكان ساعتها انا من
البنات المتفوقه اللي المفروض معاها
ضمامتها وباباها ان انا هدخل كليه من
كليات القمه ساعتها مامتي جت واتكلمت معي
قالت لي
ده
وهتركزي في الجول بتاعك اللي انت عايزاه
ساعتها كان لازم ان انا اورك هارد ان انا
عارفه ان انا هشتغل اكتر وان انا عايزه
اذاكر وعايزه اثبت لمامتي ان انا قد دي
بعديها يجي تاني ان انا كل واحد فينا
عندنا هو نسبه الناس اللي بتشتغل هنا قد
ايه ونسبه الطلاب قد ايه اللي بيشتغلوا قد
ايه
والطلاب
اوكي يبقى احنا عندنا عامه اكتر كل واحد
فينا لما بيجي بيشتغل بيبدا عنده تشالنجرز
في حياته العمليه انا حياتي العمليه
بداتها مش لوحدي بداتها بابني يعني ظهرت
جوزي بدري فطبيعي ان انا هيبقى فيه ولاد
بدري
ما خدتش بقى الموضوع لان انا لا انا من
وانا صغيره من وانا في الجامعه من وانا في
المدرسه كمان
بيقولوا عليا البني ادمه اللي بتحب شغلك
كتير وبعمل
يعني مش حاجه واحده بس بقدر فيجي ان شاء
الله بما اننا في نسبه كبيره هنا طلاب
ولسه هيبداوا حياتهم العمليه ويجي انش ان
انا داخله حياه العمليه مش لوحدي معي بيت
ومسؤوليه واولاد وانا عايزه الكيب وايت دي
وانا لما اتكلم عن حياتي هي اكزامبل لكل
تشالنج او كل حاجه ممكن تكون بتواجهنا
واحنا بنبدا حياتنا العمليه تشارلز ان انا
داخله عندي مسؤوليه كبيره وتشالنج مع
مديري اللي قال لي وانا ليه اختارك انت
لما ممكن اختار واحده يبقى شغلها وقتها
كله للشغل ما تقعدش تقولي بقى بيت واولاد
والولد تعبان والحاجات دي كلها ساعتها
اشتغلت اكتر لقيت اول مايكوليجز بيبداوا
ان هم ياخدوا كورسز وعندهم وقت ان هم
يعملوا دراسات ويكبروا من نفسهم انا ما
كانش عندي الوقت ده وساعتها يعني
[موسيقى]
وفعلا اشتغلت وحصل اساس من بعد سنه بالظبط
من الشغل ودخلنا فيه كلنا ومديري اللي كان
بيقول لي ليه اختارك انت هو اللي اختارني
تو بي بروموتد عن كل مايكوليكز اللي كانوا
موجودين
[تصفيق]
كلنا بيبقى عندنا تحديات لحد ما يجي
التشالنج اللي بتحسي بقى اللي فات ده كله
ايه ما كانش ونيجي لتش الدنيا كانت مستقره
جت مفاجاه ان انا تشالنج ابني التالت ودي
كانت مفاجاه مش قرار في الوقت ان الحياه
اصلا صعبه والوقت يا دوبك بين بقى بقى
عندي ابن في مذاكره وفي تمارين وفي الشغل
وفي البيت طب انا هعمل ايه خلاص وقفت
واقفه مع نفسي وقررت ان انا خلاص لو كان
في جول بتاع الشغل اخلي الجول ده هو يبقى
بيتي واولادي وان انا اركز معاهم واسيب
الجول بتاع الشغل ده خالص بعد كده رجعت
وفكرت تاني طب ما انت متعوده على
جديد ابداي ركزي فيه وارجعي فوكس على
وابدئي طلعي الهارد بوينت واشتغلي اكتر
وساعتها
اي حد بيوصل للمرحله ديفيل داون لازم
يلاقي لنفسهم جديد كل ما كان عندك لحاجه
جديده ده هيساعدك ان انت تقومي من اللي
انت
بتواجهيها او حاله الدعون اللي انت فيها
الجديد ده هو اللي هيشجعك على كل
المسؤوليات اللي وراكي وبدات اتبنى فكره
ان انت كسبت مهما كان عندك مشغوليات كتير
دي ممكن تكون عندي انا في صوره بيتي
واولادي وشغلي في حد تاني ممكن يبقى عنده
مسؤوليات ثانيه مهما كان عندك مسؤوليات ما
تنسيش نفسك you have to فوكس تهتمي بنفسك
تحبي نفسك تبداي تدي لنفسك وقت حتى لو خمس
دقائق في اليوم بدات اعملها بباري سمبل
بروسيس ان انا بدات استغل خبرتي انا كنت
اولادي بقالي سبع سنين في مجال الجلديه
والتجميل
بدات استغل الاكسبيرينس دي ان انا ابدا
اقول لكل ست مهما كان عندك مشغوليات خمس
دقايق في اليوم في اخر اليوم تقعدي قدام
المرايه تعملي مثلا سكين
يوم في الاسبوع ان انت تاخدي وقت تروحي
مكان تعملي ريلاكسيشن ان انت تروحي لو
عندك اي حاجه صحيه تروحي للدكتور تهتمي
بنفسك تخرجي مع صحابك ده هيفرق جدا جدا مع
نفسيتك ومع ان انت
عشان تبداي تعملي
اللي عندك عملت ده عن طريق ان انا بقى
عندي كميونيتي على الفيسبوك ان انا بطلع
اتكلم مع الستات والبنات على السبس بتاع
ان هم ازاي يهتموا ببشرتهم وشعرهم ماي
اكسبيرينس لان كان بالنسبه لي وقتها
تشالنج ان انا مش عايزه اطلع اتكلم على
السوشيال ميديا في الوقت للناس كلها
بتتكلم في حاجه انا مش فاهمه فيها او ما
يبقاش في معين بقدمه طلعت بقيت اقعد قدام
اللايف ان انا اقعد احط السكين كاروتين
بتاعي واولادي بيتنططوا حواليا بدات اجيب
دكاتره جلديه ودكاتره تغذيه ان هم يبداوا
يعرفوهم يهتموا بنفسهم ازاي ويهتموا
بشكلهم ازاي كنا لسه شايفين القصه بتاعه
استاذه فاطمه وقد ايه ممكن مظهرنا الخارجي
بيفرق جدا جدا على
نفسيتنا داخليا ودايت زينه بوش ان احنا
نعمل كل ريسبونس والجولز والاهداف اللي
عندنا
بدات الجروب تكبر
وعايزه اكبر بيضاوي انا كنت بقول ان انا
عندي طفل تالت خلاص بقى مش هقدر اكمل في
الشغل ولا هقدر اوفق ما بين البيت والشغل
ساعتها اللي هو بتاع الجروب او جروب هو
اللي خلاني اقدر اعمل التلاته يعني انا ما
قللتش لود على نفسي بالعكس انا زودت لود
على نفسي بس الباشن الجديد اللي انا طلعته
لنفسي هو ده اللي خلاني اعرف اكمل بقيه
الريستي
بدات الحياه برضو تستقر والكومنت جروب بدا
يكبر وبقت اكتر حاجه تديني معتبريشن ونرجع
ثاني لما الاقي ناس او يعني عدد من
الممبرز او اللي انا بتكلم معاهم بيقولوا
لي انت حفزتينا ان احنا نهتم بنفسنا اكثر
لما الاقي حد يبعتلي ويقول لي انا كنت
مكرره ان انا مش هنزل الشغل تاني خلاص
وانسى ان انا ابقى عندي بيبي لا انت
شجعتيني ان انا ممكن انزل واشتغل فده بيجي
دور الماضي اللي انت تركزي فيه مع حد
بيديكي تحفيز وتحفزي نفسك مش مع الناس
جروب بدات اطوره اكتر ان هو بقى حاجه
انا نازله النهارده
بتاعي ان هو از
او مكان بيعمل اوايرنس لكل ست محتاجه كل
حاجه
ان هي تلاقيها في مكان واحد دكتور جلديه
يديها كنسلتيشن الصح اللي هي عايزاها
دكتور التغذيه تقول لها ازاي تهتم بجسمها
وازاي تهتم بالتغذيه بتاعتها
يعني السوشيال ميديا او الشغل ده بدا يكبر
ويتطور كل ده وانا في عادي بيجي بقى مرحله
فوق في حياه كل واحد نقدر نقول عليه طموح
وعايز يعمل كل حاجه يجي لازم يقف مع نفسه
واقفه هل انا هعرف اعمل كل ده هعرف ادي كل
ده وقته وانجح في كل ده ساعتها نسال نفسنا
او انا سالت نفسي كام سؤال ايه اللي بيضيف
لي اكتر
هل الكوربت لايف او الشغل اللي انا بشتغله
ولا شغل السوشيال ميديا طب انا بضيف لايه
اكتر وهنا قررت اخد قرار ما كانش سهل
تماما مع وجود شغل مستقر ومعروف ويعني
معروف الكارير بتاعه بس فيه كده بيشدني
الناحيه التانيه ويقول لي عندي حاجات
كتيره قوي ممكن اعملها الناحيه الثانيه
والموضوع بس مش جاست ان هو يبقى حاجه على
السوشيال ميديا او ان انت تطلعي تتكلمي
اونلاين بس وساعتها خدت القرار ان انا
لايف
اون الفكره اللي انا اتبنتها وفكره ان انا
ابقى
نحفز ستات كتير انها تهتم بنفسها وفكره ان
انا عامه اعمل ماركتينج او ان انا ابقى
بمثل الجلديه والتجميل والهلستات
وبدات خدت القرار وخلاص بدات افوكس
فالشغل السوشيال ميديا بعد كده حسيت ان ده
يعني دايما كده كل واحد فينا لما يوصل
لجول بيحس ان هو كان شايف الجول ده بس ما
كانش ليه بس انا كنت شايفاه يعني كنت
عارفه ان انا الموضوع لما اسيب لايف
الموضوع مش هيقف على ان انا هركز على جروب
او انستقرام بس الموضوع اكبر من كده
وفعلا لقيت ان انا طول الفتره اللي انا
اشتغلتها في السوشيال ميديا ده دي كنت
بعمل اكسبيرينس جديده لنفسي ان انا
السوشيال ميديا او الشغل اللي انا كنت
بشتغله ده كنت بعمل نفسي ان انا ممكن افتح
شركه واقدر ادير انا اولادي خدت
الاكسبيرينس بتاعه لمده سبع سنين
وعايزه ادخل حته الديجيتال اكتر واعرف
افكار جديده وازاي نلاقي طرق تسويق جديده
ومبتكره لا المجال بتاعي وفعلا
اللي هو الشركه اللي انا طالعه بيها
دلوقتي التايتل بتاعي
او لشركه تسويق
وتسويق وبي ار على
الالكتروني وهنا نرجع بقى
احنا سالنا بعض سؤال في اول الطاقه كان
ايه السؤال حد فاكر
طب مين مين اللي قال
انت ممكن تقوم
انت
طيب ممكن تقول لي بقى الكلمات دي ممكن
ازاي يبقوا مرتبطين ببعض
البيس ان انت
سايكولوجيس اوكي
حلو قوي في حد عنده وجهه نظر تانيه ازاي
ان الكلمات دي ممكن تبقى مرتبطه ببعض
اتفضلي
لو انت عايزه تعملي هتلاقي ان انت ماشيه
في الاستبس دي كلها حد عنده اي راي تاني
بالزبط زي ما هي قالت انا ممكن الكلمات دي
كلها هالخصها لكم في جمله واحده ان انت اي
حاجه عايزاها في حياتك حوليها لجول حوليها
لهدف وانت ماشيه عشان تحققي الهدف ده
هتلاقي تشالنجرز عادي خليكي قد التشالنج
دي وورك هارد اشتغلي كويس قوي وفاقص على
الهدف علشان تحققيه لو جيتي ولقيتي نفسك
داون وبدات ان انت خلاص تياسي ولا انا مش
هقدر احقق الكول ده
ابدئيشن حفزي نفسك او دوري على الناس اللي
حواليك اللي تحفزك علشان
وتطلعي الباشن الشغف اللي عندك وخليك
دايما فاكره ان انت عندك ريسبونسي
ومسؤوليات تجاه الهدف بتاعك ده علشان
توصلي ليور بيكفي ثانكيو
[تصفيق]